Good evening, my lady.
Good evening, good sir.
How are you this evening?
I find myself to be most excellent this evening, yes I do.
And how do you find the tidings at Downton Abbey?
My god.
Please don't tell me that you should practice this accent.
How are you?
I'm good, thanks.
No.
Come on now, enough of this "I'm good, thanks" stuff.
How you doin'?
Honestly.
Honestly?
Yes.
Honestly, I don't know.
You know, this is our fourth date and what does it mean?
And this is a risk I'm willing to take because I like you.
And I really don't want to screw this up.
I like you too.
I do.
Shall I come in, or...
I'm actually, I'm ready to go.
Okay.
My British accent is not that bad.
Oh, it's real bad.